it is something that for one more thing
I will go in honor of Mother's Day we're
gonna do a text first up please leave
yourself enough wiggle room so that when
and if you need to you can climb out of
the Trump rabbit hole you must maintain
enough balance to access that ladder
please for all of our sakes number two
Giuliani is a nut job
how is this role helping your man three
Jessie please keep in mind that if one
continues to search for information that
only confirms our bias we never grow
change or expand our thinking check out
a different book and dare to turn the
page there's a big number for one is
right Jessie drugs are coming through
our ports of entry what are you reading
do your research and lastly follow the
oligarch money know you're getting out
there mom happy Mother's Day
very nice you're happy Mother's Day -
Jessie's thank you also yet waters row
there Saturday night 8 o'clock great
show and I'm also on the story with
Martha McCallum later tonight well
picking up on Jessie's theme I just want
to make sure that you all remember that
Sunday is Mother's Day have you broken
into that last minute sweat over what to
get that special lady well a new study
by Groupon found that 40% of moms say
they fake happiness when they get those
gifts you know what they say that all
they really want is something
sentimental that expresses that you love
them so let's give a big group hug to
the mothers on our five staff yes
here's Megan with her baby yep here's
Queen net with her child here's our pal
Kennedy and her children how about my
pal Kimberly with her son Ronan and
Romney Road Dogg terrific and here's my
wife with her three babies you didn't
have a picture of me with my ferrets but
that's okay
I know a lot of people don't think
ferrets can be children but you're just
narrow-minded and one day the ferrets
will rise and destroy you alright
Saturday 10 o'clock the Greg Gutfeld
show we have a great great ensemble
Jedediah Vila the great actor Daniel
Roebuck you got cat tip and tire it's
gonna be great show 10 o'clock Saturday
and don't forget my friends the greatest
book ever written besides the Bible the
Gutfeld monologues all the monologues
that I do here in this book order it now
pre-order it's not out yet but preorder
it you go to a like Barnes & Noble or
amazon.com or Simon sister website but
no just order painting the cover with
all the faces I love nobody made me
first book in which I act I edit my own
book and leave the notes in and say
where I went wrong
no one's ever done that I say like this
is terrible this side so long yes well
you know I hate cats because they're a
little devil hamsters a woman in Texas
she thought she found a couple of
kittens so she took him home but they
got a little bit bigger and every time
she went to feed them they would claw
and scratch her and her relatives to the
point where they were so aggressive they
were starting to do harm so she called
animal control services and it turned
out they were baby Bobcat yeah and and
they would certainly okay house cats
want to eat you but they can't because
they have tiny ineffective evil little
mouths Bobcats can't they could do a
great job and all she would have to do
is fall asleep and they would name her
face and you know ACS in Texas is
investigating her to see if she obtained
them improperly because they are wild
and of course it happened there's a lot
of them happening do you think it's like
a dog it's like a fox
so sweet with the little cute little
white face but you know just happen with
animals my friends a wild weekend right
exactly another monologues alright well
it is a fabulous Friday indeed isn't it
so we just also want to say
congratulations to to our friend Rick
Reich me as he is the fabulous
weatherman here at the Fox News Channel
and he came out with a new color for the
weatherman umbrella there fabulous Kenny
I'm gonna give this one to you really
especially for Mother's Day and this is
the pink color and we want to say thank
you so much to susan worth time for a
wonderful job 20 years here at the fox
news channel
outstanding job is much for all of your
efforts and god bless oh very nice
jealous of Mike booths you know umbrella
sales I mean the goal would be your
product Jesse